en esta Cumbre africana como muchos la
Llaman por realizarse en Egipto los
presidentes latinoamericanos todavía no
han tenido mucha presencia Y es que en
la Cumbre los únicos en hablar de la
región han sido Gustavo Petro de
Colombia y Nicolás Maduro de Venezuela
Petro propuso un decálogo en el que
reiteró la idea que tiene de que se
pague la deuda internacional con
inversión en adaptación y mitigación
pero que tanto acogida ha tenido esto en
la cop 27 nos lo explicó en France 24
digamos poca en el escenario de poder de
la Copa
pero yo creo que es la única propuesta
lógica que hoy podríamos tener si
queremos financiar a gran escala y de
verdad
la adaptación al cambio climático que es
el tema de esta copa y la mitigación
el mecanismo que se propone que es
endeudarnos más así las tasas de interés
sean más bajas no es sostenible no es
posible que los países en desarrollo ya
sobre endeudados
aumenten aún más su deuda para financiar
una serie de obras y proyectos de las
cuales realmente las sociedades en
desarrollo no son responsables porque es
el efecto somos Víctimas de quienes por
conservar altos niveles de vida
están consumiendo excesivamente carbón y
petróleo y provocando la crisis
climática varios países latinoamericanos
se han reunido con el gobierno francés
como ocurrió con chile Venezuela y
también Colombia y de hecho Petro
viajará a París para reunirse con
Emmanuel majón
yo me reuniré mañana con el presidente
macron en París y charlaremos de la
agenda común del tema venezolano y el
tema de la paz Yo he invitado al Foro
por la paz de París y ahí esta